Carrusel de las artes
[Música]
María Carolina piña
reciban un cordial saludo desde París un
placer que estén en nuestra sintonía
para este nuevo momento en el que les
proponemos una cita con la cultura y la
creación y a continuación los temas que
les hemos preparado para hoy
la biblioteca Nacional de Francia rindió
homenaje a Marcel post en el centenario
de su muerte con una exposición sobre el
proceso de escritura de su obra cumbre
en busca del tiempo perdido
haremos un viaje por la historia de la
música y de las canciones de Disney a
través de un concierto Sinfónico de gira
por toda Francia
dos dramas sociales en los estrenos del
cine francés
y en la crónica musical les hablaremos
de un espectáculo que hizo historia la
ópera rockstagmania regresa a los
escenarios en una nueva versión
[Música]
la biblioteca Nacional de Francia
conmemora los 100 años de la muerte del
escritor francés Marcel puzz con una
exposición que nos lleva por los
meandros del trabajo de composición
literaria a través de sus manuscritos
perdidos una muestra para descubrir o
releer una de las novelas más
importantes del siglo XX en busca del
tiempo perdido es un reportaje de
Melissa barra
[Música]
maxel Push la fábrica de su obra la
muestra de la biblioteca Nacional de
Francia restituye el trabajo titánico
del autor de en busca del tiempo perdido
fallecido en 1922 miles de manuscritos
de hojas sueltas corregidas anotadas y
tachadas que justo cortaba y pegado en
serie y que habían sido diseminados por
todo el planeta en los últimos 100 años
se exponen para mostrar la historia
escondida de la novela a la que el
escritor dedicó toda una vida guiónfo es
uno de los comisarios de esta exposición
que comienza con una de las oraciones
más célebres de la literatura mundial
Esa primera frase durante mucho tiempo
me ha costado temprano Marcel proust no
le escribió en un solo día la
perfeccionó entre 1909 y 1912 durante
esos años Tuvo muchos vaivenes muchas
dudas escribió versiones en cuadernos
borradores y muchas satisfacción luego
las mecanografía y siguió aportando
correcciones con su pluma hasta
encontrar la frase definitiva mostramos
todo ese proceso de elaboración del
texto
también muestra cómo la famosa Magdalena
de Push que se convirtió en toda una
figura literaria pudo haber sido muy
distinta en el primer tomo titulado por
el camino de Swan
[Música]
al principio debía ser un pedazo de pan
viejo o sea un objeto popular banal
luego se convirtió en pan tostado y
después una simple tostada cuando le
puso el toque final al texto se inventó
la famosa Magdalena la galleta con la
que confirió la connotación poética
religiosa y erótica que buscaba Marcel
brunson
Marcel sin duda uno de los autores más
enigmáticos que ha dejado a la
imaginación de sus lectores la libertad
de definir lo que es ficticio y lo que
es autobiográfico en una obra que aborda
ampliamente temas poco usuales en su
época
[Música]
como titulado Sodoma y Gomorra pone al
narrador En la cima del París mundano
para mostrar lo que se esconde detrás en
especial lo que llamaban la inversión
sexual aquí encarnada en el personaje
del Barón de charlots y los manuscritos
revelan todo el trabajo de
profundización sobre el tema de la
homosexualidad
justo falleció antes de publicarse los
últimos tomos de la novela fue su
hermano gobec quien rescató los
borradores y fragmentos que el autor no
alcanzó a quemar incluido el final de la
novela el tiempo recobrado
sabemos que escribió la última frase que
acaba con las palabras en el tiempo
mucho antes de morir redactó el final de
1917 pero después siguió mejorando la
trama y se entregó completamente a su
creación hasta el último respiro su vida
y la de su personaje principal convergen
el narrador atraviesa muchas etapas y
decide al final convertirse en escritor
porque solo la literatura y el arte le
permiten detener el tiempo alcanzar lo
eterno y rescatar el recuerdo
[Música]
todos conocemos una o muchas películas
de Disney pero alguna vez han puesto
atención a la banda musical de esas
películas es lo que pone de relieve
Disney en concierto en el que se
interpretan algunos de los temas más
conocidos que Disney ha compuesto en
casi 100 años de existencia
[Música]
la riqueza musical de Disney en un
espectáculo grandioso con una orquesta
sinfónica y cantantes en vivo custom
hits es el director de orquesta de
Disney en concierto
en el programa hay muchas músicas y
estilos diferentes que han atravesado
las épocas hay partituras que en su
momento fueron escritas para orquestas
sinfónica hay otras como Frozen que son
más actuales en 100 años de historia los
numerosos compositores de Disney se
inspiraron de estilos muy distintos
desde el chat hasta el rock la música
clásica o pop para crear el universo de
cada película es fascinante la
diversidad musical de Disney
Calixto y Charlotte ardió son las voces
francesas de bayana y Elsa
me encanta hacer este concierto porque
soy cantante profesional hay una ola de
emoción además baiana es una princesa
independiente ella representa valores
muy importantes hoy y me gusta mostrar
eso a los niños que nos miran
es un concierto para todas las edades
hay personajes muy recientes como bayana
o Elsa pero también canciones de
películas de hace 50 o 60 años como La
Sirenita o el libro de la selva las
canciones están también escritas que es
muy fácil cantarlas con una orquesta
sinfónica somos 70 artistas en escena en
simbiosis total y eso es mágico
[Música]
[Aplausos]
proyectos como este permiten que un
público muy amplio pueda ver y escuchar
una orquesta sinfónica es una
experiencia impresionante a veces la
gente se nos acerca al final del
concierto para decirnos que pasaron un
momento maravilloso
[Música]
y del Disney pasamos al resto del cine a
continuación dos películas que pasaron
por el festival de cares y que salen
esta semana en las salas de cine
francesas
[Música]
le pilla los peores primer largometraje
de las directoras Lisa coca y Román
virrey cuenta el rodaje con un grupo de
niños y adolescentes en un Barrio pobre
en el norte de Francia
es en realidad una película dentro de
otra a veces salvaje a veces tierna una
autocrítica al mundo del Séptimo arte
francés y su deseo de generar cines
social esta cinta entre realidad y
ficción fue galardonada con el premio
una cierta mirada del último festival de
cine de cannes
[Música]
nuestros hermanos abordan la pantalla
grande dos muertes dramáticas a manos de
la policía francesa La del joven Malik
usequina durante las manifestaciones de
estudiantes en 1986 y la de otro
muchacho argentino asesinado por la
policía
la película describe un momento
tumultuoso en Francia y la manera en que
el Ministerio de interiores trató de
acallar estos casos su director el
Franco argelino también evoca el racismo
y la solidaridad de los artistas
franceses
[Música]
pasamos ahora a nuestra Crónica musical
en la que les hablaremos del regreso de
una obra que marcó un hito en la
historia de la canción francesa
stalkmanía es una Ópera rock compuesta
en los años 80 y de eso nos habla hoy
Natalia Olivares Hola Natalia Hola María
Carolina y es importante sobre todo
porque es una de las únicas obras
escritas en francés para un público
francés fue pensada y escrita por el
francés Michael con textos de Louis
plamundo originario de Quebec es una
mezcla de dos culturas un punto común el
francés pues y la voluntad de hacer las
cosas en grande el resultado es esta
mañana y hoy 40 años después es una
starmaña renovada
[Música]
amor
esta mañana sobrevivió a toda la
generaciones María Carolina Todos aquí
grandes pequeños menos pequeños tenemos
en mente o conocemos unas de las
canciones de estas mañas pero hoy el
objetivo de tu mayor y el nuevo director
artístico es darle importancia al
libreto y recordar lo que los autores
quisieron
contaría es un trabajo donde las
canciones han tomado el poder es decir
son legendarias mucha gente las conoce
las canta las ama y eso es obvio porque
Son increíbles pero al mismo tiempo han
opacado un poco la narración de
starmanía El propósito para mí era
importante volver a revelar el sentido
de la obra porque poca gente sabe lo que
dice esta armonía mi reto era destacar
la línea narrativa
y la línea narrativa es contar la vida
de monopolis esa ciudad del futuro en
ese entonces eran el futuro el año 2000
o sea eran los años 2000 el futuro ahora
ya no pero
contaba que era una ciudad donde vivía
gente en los subterráneos con una
contaminación
agobiante donde la carrera hacia el
poder mataba y donde los jóvenes vivían
en la obsesión de querer ser algún día
estrellas Eso era lo que contaba Nataly
nos hablabas de tu mayoría el director
de esa nueva starmania Tomás Yoli que es
actor director de teatro de ópera y que
ha sido escogido para esos Juegos
Olímpicos que van a tener lugar en París
en 2024 exactamente y por eso por todas
esa experiencia tu mayoría el más
indicado y según él esta ópera moderna
esa Ópera rock tiene todas las
condiciones de una ópera Classic clásica
perdón de un drama y así no los contó
diciendo que además era una ópera más
que visionaria
esta armonía es una obra visionaria que
todavía nos lleva a la delantera habla
de Ecología de terrorismo de eco
ansiedad de los concursos televisivos
creadores de artistas populares habla
del poder de los medios de comunicación
y de temas de género el personaje de
sadia por ejemplo es un hombre que se
vive a lo femenino y esto no es un
problema para nadie Sí también es un
personaje homosexual que vive muy bien
su sexualidad y tampoco es un problema
para nadie excepto para marylan que está
enamorada de él porque su amor no será
correspondido esta armonía es una obra
sobre la angustia del ser humano cuando
se proyecta en el futuro
[Música]
Natalia y esas canciones de esta manera
ha sido retomadas por muchos artistas
internacionales una de ellas fue selin
Dios los vamos a dejar con esa
interpretación de ziggy un chico
diferente por selindio Muchísimas
gracias por su sintonía y hasta la
próxima
[Música]